et on en parle avec olivier d'organes ce
bonjour vous êtes avocat au cabinet a
search vous êtes surtout expert en
sanctions économiques on vient
d'entendre bruno le maire nous allons
provoquer l'effondrement de l'économie
l'économie russe parmi la série de
mesures annoncées quels sont selon vous
celles qui sont le plus efficaces
celles qui seront les plus efficaces
très clairement ce sont les sanctions
qui visent le système financier russe
notamment les banques qui ont été pour
certaines places et soulisse déjà fait
d'avoir également les mesures qui ont
été annoncées en fin d'après-midi et
précisant pour l'après midi hier contre
la banque centrale de russie convocation
à empêcher la banque centrale de russie
d'utiliser les réserves qu'elle a
accumulées ces dernières dernières
années pour porter secours aux
entreprises russes qui vont commencer à
ressentir l'effet de ces sanctions a
justement sur l'effet de ces sanctions
comment l'économie à elle peut résister
l'économie que résister de par la
préparation qui a été entreprise par la
russie depuis le rejet net la russie a
accumulé un nombre très important de
réserves notamment elle a également
restructurer profondément sa tête cet
atelier fait partie des débats publics
les plus basses de des grandes et grands
puissances économiques est par ailleurs
la russie peut espérer même si c'est un
petit peu plus ambigu aujourd'hui que ça
ne m'était ya une semaine un éventuel
soutien de la part de la chine mais en
tout cas les sanctions qui ont été
adoptés sont d'une telle violence est
tellement inédite dans leur histoire que
l voile à l'école reçoit avoir bien du
mal à supporter l ses sanctions sur le
long cours on a compris le nerf de la
guerre entre guillemets c'est l'énergie
sega c'est le pétrole dont la russie est
très riche des géants des hydrocarbures
comme celle par exemple bp ou encore
total energy se désengage justement de
ce marché russe quel va être l'impact
pour les russes et l' impact aussi pour
nous européens
alors l'impact pour les européens c'est
est ce qu'il ya c'est ce qui a justifié
en tout cas une forme de réserve de la
part de l'union européenne sur les
sanctions sur ce secteur on est encore
en plein coeur de l'hiver on est encore
des tendances très fortement alors
peut-être pas forcément la france mais
nos voisins européens sont très
dépendants du gaz russe sont notamment
l'allemagne et l'italie donc on n'a pas
souhaité
aujourd'hui encore imposé de sanctions
spécifiques sur ces produits mais les
investissements successifs de shell et 2
et 2 et de bp en russie et la position
de non nouvel investissement de la part
de total une énergie vont apporter de
grandes difficultés techniques elle a à
la russie pour autant aujourd'hui encore
la russie a annoncé la signature d'un
partenariat important entre gazprom et
la chine et donc il est aussi fort à
parier que le marché chinois et certains
marchés qui permettent à la russie de
continuer à exporter une partie de son
gaz alors il va y avoir un impact sur de
ses sanctions sur les économies
européennes notamment sur le prix de
l'essence le prix de gaz on parle de
décence qui déjà un plus haut depuis
depuis des années
oui très clairement après l'augmentation
des prix de l'énergie elle et elle est
conjoncturelle ne datent pas de cette
crise les prix de l'énergie avaient
atteint des sommets déjà bien avant
l'incursion militaire russe sur le
territoire ukrainien par ailleurs
l'augmentation de l'inflation des prix
en matière et gazière elle est aussi
liée au contexte géopolitique
tendu inédit et donc de fait très
clairement ce sont ces chèques ce cumul
de facteurs qui contribuent aujourd'hui
avoir une inflation des prix et donc
l'inflation des prix pour le
consommateur
que peut faire concrètement le kremlin
contre l'union européenne et que contre
tous est cesser toutes ces sanctions qui
sont en train d'être prises contre
moscou
très concrètement le kremlin peut
espérer capitaliser sur les nombreux
investissements étrangers directs
français européens sur le territoire
russe une des possibilités qui
s'offriront aux gamins et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'a annoncé vladimir
poutine aussi récemment que vendredi
dernier serait de prendre des
contre-mesures qui viendrait de viser
des actifs financiers français et
étrangers sur le territoire russe on
peut éventuellement penser dans un
scénario maximaliste à des
nationalisations par exemple des
participations de grands groupes
français dans des dents des
joint-ventures ou d'autres partenariats
signés avec des entreprises russes qui
serait relativement à désastreux
d'emprunt de l'économie que les clés les
comprend les investissements directs
français en russie représente plusieurs
dizaines de milliards d'euros boris
johnson parle et olaf scholz aussi le
championnat allemand parle de nous au
train de sanctions très prochainement
comment sanctionner encore plus de la
dîmière poutine alors il ya deux
dernières mesures de sanctions qui n'ont
pas été prises la première ce sont des
sanctions qui ont trait aux fectivement
secteur gazier vous le disiez tout à
l'heure le secteur gaz et les imports ne
sont toujours pas interdit au niveau
européen on pourrait envisager notamment
au fur et à mesure de la sortie de
l'hiver des sanctions sur ce secteur qui
viendraient considérablement appauvrir
la russie qui dépend très fortement de
ses exports de de gaz et de pétrole ça
c'est la première série de sanctions et
la deuxième série ce serait de
complètement death wish they l'économie
risque on sait qu'aujourd'hui les
premières banques russes qu'ils vont
être sortis de swift dont être vont être
annoncées mais on pourrait envisager de
faire un tout un blocus total de 2,2
swift et interdira tout le système
bancaire russe d'avoir accès à ses
services de messagerie une dernière
question en comparaison des sanctions
contre la corée du nord et notamment
l'iran comment on peut évaluer ses
sanctions contre la russie c'est du même
niveau
elles sont par rapport à ce qu'ils aient
les sanctions existantes contre l'iran
la corée du nord elles sont un petit peu
moins complexe ou en tout cas moins
transverses en terme d'activité et par
contre il faut pas sous-estimer le fait
que la russie en partenaire commercial
de premier plan dans nombre de
démocraties occidentales et donc elles
sont paradoxalement même si elles sont
peut-être moins largement étendue que
les sanctions contre l'iran et la corée
du nord elles sont peut-être elles ont
des effets potentiellement beaucoup plus
grand sur l'économie mondiale et sur
l'économie russe parce que la russie est
un pays une puissance économique de
premier plan et que les sanctions dont
vous fait unis dont vous parlez sont des
sanctions qui ont été prononcées à
l'encontre de pays qui avaient des
économie moins dépendante de l'occident
et du dollar notamment merci beaucoup
olivier d'organes d'avoir été en direct